all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath live
this is comedians on skype talking
comedy if you are watching this on
YouTube just know that all the questions
are being asked in our Facebook group so
if you'd like to join the hot breath
comedy Network Facebook group just click
the link in the description and you will
be connecting with comedians like
today's guests so without further ado
please welcome to the show the one and
only Alonzo Bodden everyone give it up
for Alonzo Bodden hello Joel how are you
I am splendid and thrilled to have you
I'm gonna assume that I got some kind of
virtual applause on that intro yes yeah
we have sound effects they don't come
through Skype but they do come through
the group so there was an applause sound
effect for you we'll do an air horn as
well just the turn don't do an air now
your turn good morning zoo radio oh I
miss doing though I miss morning radio
you miss I hear most comics talk about
just how terrible and crazy it was it
was but you know back in the day which I
kind of missed but it was it was huge in
the 80s and but even in the 90s that was
the best way to sell tickets you know
it's still a great way to sell tickets
the problem is you don't have as many
big-name local DJ's as you used to but
when they used to be like a big-name
local DJ and you got on his show
Thursday or Friday morning mainly
Thursday morning you could sell out your
weekend off one individually oh he's in
town yeah oh yeah not used to uh but now
those things are going it's all like
yeah social media and you kind of at
this point it's weird it's almost like
the comedian has to bring the following
to the comedy clubs instead of the other
way around now I'd say it's 95 percent
that you know and in talking to you like
we
joking about you being the younger one
now and stuff but one of the tips I give
all new comics who asked me is your
marketing is up to you and it's
something I didn't learn I didn't learn
I finally have a good social media
person and she's really working on
stepping up my posts and videos and this
and that but now yet they expect comics
100% to do all their own marketing you
know some of the clubs that have been
around a long time will have a good
relationship with local radio or morning
TV but they expect the comic to do it
and it's funny you said you have a
social media like person because Nate
bargatze was on here and he had the
exact same he it's like almost an
extension of your job now he outsourced
to social media to a company that now
kind of makes that almost his billboard
for getting people to shows yeah I mean
it's the thing about it is there's no
setup for it there's no set way to do it
so I've had a couple of people who said
oh I do social media and they've been
shitty or half-ass you know this person
now I have now is great and it's very
professional but like many things in our
business manager publicist social media
whatever there is no you don't go to
college to do it there's no rating of it
anyone can say that they do it you don't
find out if they're good or not unless
you have a friend or you know someone
you know who work with them or you try
them yourself so you you learn different
things I remember when I started you
know cuz everybody wants to be a manager
I'm a manager I'm a manager and Jamie
Masada who runs a Laugh Factory he told
me if someone wants to manage you have
them call NBC because if NBC won't take
their call then you might as well be
calling yourself right because meaning
the point being that networks and stuff
they talk to professionals and if you if
your person doesn't know who to call at
NBC or
you know today at Netflix or Amazon or
whatever you know then yeah you might as
well be doing it yourself you need you
know so when someone claims to be
something that that's not necessarily
true I have found a big red flag with
that is if someone is leading with I
know so-and-so and so-and-so or I'm
connected with this and that I feel like
if they lead with that in my experience
it's always been a dead-end street yeah
because then they're trying to do to
validate themselves
another thing is simply do they pay for
lunch
they don't pay with you seriously yeah
what meeting you and they don't pay
that's a [ __ ] person that's a
[ __ ] operation they if they you know
so now it's different levels right again
I don't know what level you are in the
comedy game because when I you know when
I started out you know you you're doing
it yourself and then it was one point
where my manager and I use that in
quotes we're still friends and she's
great but the reason I signed with her I
wouldn't even call her manager of my
booking agent my agent whatever she had
connections with the other club owners
like when you're on the feature level
right you have a lot of club owners in
the Midwest in the south or whatever and
they call themselves an agent I'm your
manager now and what that means is they
book a bunch of clubs they know other
people who book clubs and they'll trade
spots they're like oh I'll let my guy
you know if you put my guy up in Spokane
and and Seattle and Billings Montana and
I'll put your guy up and you know Idaho
Iowa and whatever you know you know I
mean but that's what works on that left
but they're they're working below the TV
a level if that makes sense below the
major level but then there's a comic
when you move up when you start getting
involved in the majors and this is what
happened with me when I moved up and
started doing late-night TV and some
Hollywood stuff
then I told her I said look I gotta get
mail a person I gotta get someone
connected in this world and she
understood she was like yeah you do cuz
cuz she you know she was based I think
she was based somewhere in Washington or
whatever whatever it was she wasn't
based in LA or New York so she wasn't
connected in that level just like if you
sign with a big agency and I had this
happen I was through William Morris when
I was had nothing going on and William
Morris couldn't do a thing because they
don't develop and sell you the way they
used to like we were talking about they
want you to be it so yeah and that's
different levels different people we
just we had um
Tamara Goins the head of comedy
innovative artists and her whole thing
was like don't have a manager until you
have something to manage you know it's
like you got to bring something to the
table
pretty much yeah I know Tim I used to be
with innovative oh snap oh yeah you bet
we've been to a comedy most 30 years
she's probably maybe been a little bit
everywhere 20 87 years but that's so
cool yeah and an old Jon REEP was
actually on here and he wanted me to say
hello to you cuz you were the judge when
he was on last comics and we're having
some years when he lived in LA we live
I'm sorry really we're having a daughter
we're having a delay thing online
together where can you hear me yeah
sorry we're um no I'm saying we MF Oh
half and I just did something together
on healed for helium comedy clubs
they're doing Q&A s to raise money for
their staff and employees and Reap and I
used to be neighbors and it was honey
because we lived in a complex that was
so big there were over 300 units we
would never see each other around the
building we'd only see each other at the
airport and you still live there yeah
yeah I love it
and speaking of we're about to get into
the questions here speaking of a Q&A
this is a live Q&A but I have to
selfishly ask first because this is a
comedy advice show and I know when you
were the door
man at Laugh Factory you would get a lot
of advice from comics like Dom our era
and George Wallace and I have to ask
like what is some of your favorite or
most helpful advice you've gotten from
them or other comics of their caliber
well I'll tell you it wasn't as much
advice back then as watching them work
you know there's times when you just
shut up and watch but what I'll tell you
what I learned from George George always
has a pad with him you will never see
George without the yellow pad and
adolescent was always be writing always
or be ready to write something funny
happens you think of something you see
something write it down write it down
write it down that's what I got from
George Wallace from dahm dahm stays in
the moment Dom would always open in the
moment I always like that say something
about what he sees in the crowd or what
just happened but but it was more just
watching him his comfort onstage his
personality I remember I remember a
thing I got from down I was doing my set
and I was sitting on the stool and he
just looked at me what can't stand for
20 minutes right and it was like okay
Dom I see I gotta put a little energy
into this a great piece of advice I got
from George Lopez back then rodney was
it Rodney Dangerfield was in and he used
to drop in the factory in due time or
whatever which was amazing you know but
anyway this woman went on after Rodney
and she was talking about Rodney like
Rodney - Rodney that right and George
said when a star shows up never mention
them crowd knows who they are you gotta
be who you you got to bring your you
know you got to bring it yourself you
got to show them who you are so so
there's no sense telling the crowd that
they just saw Rodney Dangerfield they
know and and and and I had a thing
happened with that some time later where
they had a thing called
it was chocolate sundaes which is like a
black comedy show on Sunday night I've
done that and they had we yeah of course
we had um Chris Rock and Chris Tucker
did the show that night and then I had
to go up at like midnight 12:30 so when
you follow both of them you know and and
it was funny because both of them talked
about their families and their you know
family asking for money and this and
that and I just went up and said to the
crowd man if I ever make ten million
dollars and I complain about my family
asking for money you feel free to whip
my ass so that was some of the advice I
got that I remember you know yeah so
even speaking of your style and your
writing I'd love to get into that a
little bit especially since you being
more topical driven and it can be tough
and there can be a lot of parallel
thinking especially on topics that are
more topical and current how are you
able to create topical material that's
unique to you well some things if you're
gonna be top if you're gonna do topical
some things you just do right away cuz
the shelf life is gonna be short okay
the entire trump presidency is that
because any stupid thing he says he's
gonna say something else a day or two
later so you don't have time to polish
those jokes if it comes up you just
throw it out there when it comes to
other things what I look for I tried it
I try to look for a point of view I
haven't heard someone else talk about
that's what I I and you can't always do
that I mean there is parallel thought
and there's so many people out there
that it's almost I wouldn't say imposter
it's not impossible because you develop
your own voice but when you're doing
topical it's you you have to understand
there isn't time to polish every joke
because some things are going to come
and go and then
other things are evergreen and you just
really get into what you think about it
so if I'm talking about an evergreen
topic or more or less evergreen topic
like racism or me - or guns
school shooting something like that then
I get into my thoughts in my view on it
and and go with that you know there are
certain comics that I can't watch too
much because I'll start doing them
mm-hmm
Lewis Black is one if i watch Lou too
much because I love Lou he's a friend
and and I'm a huge fan but if I watch
Lou too much I'll start doing a Louis
black type rant you know and and I don't
want to do that because that's his there
was a period where I was running into a
lot and this was I I kind of started
really getting into social commentary
after Last Comic Standing but there was
a period let's say in mid 2000s that I
found myself have early mid 2000s having
a lot of parallel thought with Chris
Rock and what I thought about that was
damn I must be on the right track if I'm
having the same idea is him I'm doing
something right you know so but but the
other thing is and this goes back to
Robin Williams I don't know if you heard
those stories but yes when someone when
someone famous or big-name does it on TV
or something then you got to let it go
because no one's gonna believe you
thought of it but that's okay because
you'll think of something else you know
I'm not gonna sit here and argue that I
thought of a joke the same as Chris Rock
or I thought of it before he did or that
there's no sense having that argument so
I'll just do something else just keep
writing at the end of the day you know
yeah especially if you're topical you
know and the other thing is jokes lead
to jokes you know I mean so when you're
right if you're writing something and
you're working on this idea then you're
like oh what about this well that's a
noun that's another idea and then and
this is
part we lose now because there's really
nowhere to perform you'll do it on to
stage and people will laugh at something
you didn't realize they were gonna laugh
at so you say you were aiming this way
for the joke and they laughed at
something over here now when you're new
you get mad and you want to make your
joke work but once you learn some [ __ ]
and you're like oh shut up let them
laugh at that let's see what's over
there you know so it happens different
ways and when you're thinking of topical
material what is your process in terms
of like do you hear something and your
sense of humor is almost like a spidey
sense to where I like that topic is
worth exploring verse that topic isn't
really worth exploring like how do you
put it through the filter of like what's
gonna be worth the time to write
material about no I go it's what makes
me laugh I'll just come a news junkie I
mean I well you got to trust yourself
right because it's a comic remember when
you go on stage what you're doing is
you're showing the crowd the world
through your eyes right that that's what
the funny is you get them to see it
through
something they look at every day
suddenly you say it and they're like oh
I never thought of that and it's funny
like that's the underlying process right
so if it makes me laugh then I go with
it now as I was saying I'm a news junkie
so I read a lot of news I read different
news sources different stories and
things come up and over time and again
this is why comedy takes time to get
good at I learned to trust myself so I'm
not testing if it's funny when I talk to
the crowd because I believe I'm
confident that I know what's funny and
and in confidence is part of it if you
deliver it confidently then the crowd
gets it I always say like when people
talk about certain words certain topics
like oh you can't talk about that and
and I don't know where I learned this
but it's really true if you're afraid to
say it
they're afraid to hear it
[Music]
whoo that just gave me goose along as
long as you're not afraid to say it as
long as you're not afraid to say it it's
okay but if you're worried you can can I
say this like no then they can't hear it
so that's when you come to jokes about
topics that the crowd may not be ready
for you know dude I have interviewed
over 200 comedians that is one of my
favorite quotes if you're afraid to say
it they're afraid to hear it oh my gosh
yeah that's a mic drop all right I'll
tell you where that comes up that comes
up now politically right because people
will say to me oh do you do that joke in
the south would you do that joke in a
red state I'm like hell yeah I'll give a
[ __ ] so they're gonna you know and the
other thing is the really hardcore
conservatives never come to comedy shows
because they have no sense of humor but
but yeah I'll say it because it's it's
you know what am I gonna change my act
every city I go to so I don't hurt
anybody you know it's ridiculous exactly
so let's let's get into the viewer
questions here now wow man that gave me
the okay me the shivers right there
that's a that's a winning quote right
there I've never said the shivers before
either I don't know why I decided to
break that one out on this QA someone
just said hell yeah though I Marie says
hell yeah on that so yeah that's that's
golden so first question here from the
hot breath averse comes from Sandy she
says how hard was it to make the
transition from stand-up to acting did
you have any acting experience before
doing stand-up I don't think I've made
the transition I never really considered
myself an actor I've had some acting
roles they're pretty stereotypical as
security guy bouncer etc because I'm a
big guy I did take some acting classes
and I actually had a great acting coach
but what happened was my stand-up career
started taking off you know I I did last
comic and and you know I started doing a
late-night and in sheave and said
she said you know your thing is stand up
like that's your love that's your
passion so go do that in retrospect
maybe I could have stayed in acting
classes and become a better actor some
comics or great actors Craig Robinson
and I joke about it because Craig and I
we had the same agent and we would go on
the same auditions and this and that and
and it was kind of like she became this
actor and great yeah and and he's a
great actor he's really funny and I
became a stand-up and I started doing
well in stand-up and one day we were out
somewhere in our agent said man I got a
stand-up who wants to act and I got an
actor who wants to do stand-up so thank
thank you whoever put that in I do
audition if you want to act go to acting
class learn and do it it is it's a
talent but it's also a skill to be
learned and and respect it as such
respect it as such because when you go
on auditions you're gonna be going up
against professional actors who do it
all the time and you want to be good Oh
coming up next oh boy here's a winning
name mama bird the comedian here we go
said how would you advise those of us
still trying to keep our names and
comedy what can we do from home to keep
our comedy fresh alive and keep the
audience remembering who we are
oh you got to use social media now so
we're where people are on Instagram do
an Instagram live doing things like this
this kind of interview doing podcast
doing YouTube stuff that's what you got
to do because there's nowhere to get up
I mean I'm doing a virtual comedy club
may 7th it's called a nowhere comedy
club and it's it's we're gonna do it
through zoom but it's set up like a read
like a regular comedy club The Laugh
Factory in Hollywood they do a live
stream where you get up and you perform
for no audience but they put it
on YouTube so it looks you're actually
at the club in on stage now the thing
about that is you'd have to be
established enough to be a Laugh Factory
regular to get to do that you know so if
you're not at that level if you don't
have a club or something like that then
you got to just do it yourself
boom do it yourself that's what we're
it's what we're doing here right now
that was a big motivator of this was I
did this show for a long time it was
like I don't want to do Skype I want to
meet the comics and I want to have that
connection and then we got quarantined
and I was like all right I guess skypes
the new wave for this so I've been doing
more of these I haven't really been
doing many virtual open mics and things
like that I've really been focused on
like building this show up more so till
we get back on stage all right next
pregunta this comes from jacob Hoffmeyer
hope I'm saying your name right he says
any advice for beginners that tend to
lean towards heavy weight topics when to
pull punches when not I would say don't
I would say this though remember to be
funny no I have a have a friend and he's
a great comic and he wasn't getting
booked and I was talking to the talent
guy at the Just for Laughs festival and
we love he said
we love him but he's too caught up in a
message he forgot the funny so if you're
if you want to go heavyweight and and I
don't even know what that means anymore
but if you want to just remember to make
it funny and that was advice I got early
on was like a lot of people want to be
like a George Carlin but it's like first
figure out how to make the weather funny
before you try to take on like the
military industrial complex it's like
just figure out how to be funny first
and then you can start to apply that to
bigger maybe less funny topics yeah the
the highest compliment I've ever
received in my career was being called
us
spawn of Karlin that that's as good as
its ever gonna get if you if you're a
topical or social commentary comic but
yeah you got to learn to be funny first
you gotta remember to funny because
otherwise you're preaching in which case
you could start a megachurch and make
big money man as money in that and it's
all cash free had only I known you're
too far in now almost thirty years
there's no going back now I mean to you
yeah
Charles Newby asks how after kovat how
do you see comedy adapting we don't know
we don't know I think it will be back at
the clubs we'll be back live performance
we'll be back it's gonna take a while
the reason there are some naysayers and
doomsday people saying comedy is gonna
go away it will never go away because
we're the truth tellers they will always
need us because we tell the truth and as
the news becomes worse in a sense of it
becomes more of an entertainment show in
an opinion show than actual information
comics will become even more important
because we're the ones who don't give a
[ __ ] like yeah this is what happened
like you know if Trump says and and I
just use him because he so dominates the
news cycle it's annoying but if he says
you should inject bleach or cleaning
stuff into your body and the next day he
says no I was being sarcastic
you know the reporters listen to comics
like that's [ __ ] you don't even know
what sarcasm is you thought we were
gonna shoot up bleach because you're an
idiot
yeah you know the only of comics gonna
say that the news people will never say
it so comedy ain't going nowhere where
the truth tellers it's just gonna take a
while to get people out to get people in
the same room people breathing on each
other and but we'll be back and while
we're waiting to get back Mohammed Osman
asks during these times do you recommend
comedians do the online open mics and
shows like that why not
what else you got to do go alright right
yeah what else you got to destroy not
yep I know some people who are saying
the virtual shows suck and this and that
the other I do them I've done a few it's
not the same as doing it live you don't
get the same response to me it's more
like doing radio when you do radio you
say something funny you don't know if
people driving in the car or whatever or
listening to work or laughing when you
say it so you just put it out there but
what else you gonna do perfect yeah are
you under are you in an open mic level
in deciding I'm too good to do this
already cutting corners two years in
they're already trying to find the angle
on how to outsmart the work right that's
a great point
all right just a few more here kids
let's see we have oh I can I can give it
a few more minutes we can go give it a
few more move we're going we're going
into overtime with Alonzo Bodden round
of applause we hit the checkpoint I feel
like we're playing cruisin USA right now
we hit the checkpoint so that's very
generous thank you Alonzo Wayne flake
junior asks do you have any techniques
when writing well I can write quicker
now just because I've been doing it a
long time so initially what I learned
was write out the whole story write out
the whole idea then start removing what
isn't funny you know for example if the
joke is about a guy crossing the street
and you right I was walking across
Hollywood Boulevard on a rainy night
it's like well are we gonna talk about
Hollywood or rain if not I was just
walking across the boulevard that night
you know what I mean so you get to it
quicker
now I've been doing it so long that I
tend to write quicker you know and and
the bad thing about that though is
sometimes I'm not descriptive enough
my writing and so you find the balance
you find is what we talked about about
your voice you write it the way you
would say it just like if you work as a
professional writer okay if you're a
joke writer for people I have a friend
named Sully McCullough he writes for a
ton of comics he writes for Jamie Foxx
he writes for Anthony Anderson he writes
for the Wayans brothers etc she can
write in each of their voices because he
knows how Jamie delivers how Anthony
delivers etc so you develop that for
your own voice and when you say being
descriptive enough is that like you're
talking about being on Hollywood
Boulevard is it talking about details
within like the weather or the people
around you what kind of does what kind
of like descriptive language are you
talking well I'll give you a couple of
examples okay one example entirely taboo
now but if you go back and listen to
Bill Cosby tell a story if you watch
himself by Bill Cosby you will see a
master storyteller giving funny details
but painting an entire picture with
words and that's how to do it
fluffy Gabe Iglesias is very good at
that because Gabe gives voices to a
bunch of different things or all of his
little friends in the story and stuff
like that so they they paint a picture
with the words you know that which is
great and I'm not that that they're very
descriptive in their storytelling
storytelling comics are like that and
very good at doing that then you have
again like like me or like if you
watched Chappelle doesn't Chappell
Chappell and Louis black do something
that I watched that that I love and I
try to do it myself but you got to be
really confident to do that this they
will explain what they're talking about
they will take time to explain it and
then make it funny on Chappelle's I
think one of his Netflix specials wanted
more recent ones he did a thing about
Emmett Till
and he explained who Emmett Till was and
what happened for those who don't know
Emmett Till was a 14 year old from
Chicago went to visit family in
Mississippi because he was from Chicago
he didn't know all the segregation rule
blah blah blah he was accused of looking
at a white woman they beat him to death
and hung him and and it's a very heavy
topic and it's a very famous picture
because his mother showed his body so
that the world would see this is what
they did to a 14 year old child well
dave told that whole story
to set up what he wanted to talk about
now as a comic that takes a lot of
bravery and courage because you can see
just how to mood change when I just told
it right now to do that and then go into
comedy about it was amazing but that's
that's the best in the world and the
confidence he has to do it you know what
I mean so when you talk about using
words to paint a picture or set up a
situation Lew Lewis black will talk
about some congressmen you haven't heard
of passing a bill and he'll explain ODIs
congressman is from you know blah blah
blah and this and that and he'll make
fun of the town they're from and what
the [ __ ] are they thinking and this and
that and then he'll go into his joke you
know that takes a certain confidence
because you're taking time out you have
a limited time onstage and you're taking
time out to explain something to make it
funny so it takes time to do that
confidence to do that you and again
you'll find your style your style is
gonna be somewhere between that and
between a quick setup punch kind of joke
and when we're thinking about talking in
your voice onstage
Charles chimed in with like what is your
favorite method of rehearsal and do you
rehearse your jokes out loud to kind of
find your voice within the words no not
anymore not anymore that was a long time
ago now my rehearsals are on stage you
know they're early on when you start out
I tell comics you got to memorize
you're five minutes you're six minutes
you're three minutes whatever backwards
and forward because when you're new and
you're nervous and you get on stage the
first thing it goes is your memory and
you forget what you were gonna say and
then you start stammering or whatever
but but I mean you know I've been doing
this for 27 years my brain is so trained
to remain and sometimes I forget
whenever you walk offstage any comic
walks off stage we're thinking about the
joke we forgot to tell the bit we forgot
to do but you it is just the nature of
the beast you know you use so I don't
rehearse
I don't rehearse as far as trying to
memorize it offstage I will write a set
list and try to memorize a set list and
when I do TV I'll definitely try to
stick to the set list and yeah but
otherwise no I don't rehearse the
rehearsal like if I'm doing a TV spot
the rehearsal is the 10:00 comedy club
spots leading up to the TV spot mm-hmm
all right let's do let's do two more
here and this this comes from Justin
Williams and he asks do you give a
closer listen to your opener to gauge
what set you're going to do no I am I
will sometimes I don't listen at all if
I do listen it's only to see if we're
doing any of the same topics but now I
don't I don't definitely I'm not gonna
gauge the audience based on how do you
open or does mm-hmm what do you what do
you gauge the audience how do you like
read a crowd I don't I mean I do it once
I get on stage I don't plan ahead
because you know people will surprise
you it will net it won't be what you
think right so so I'll be somewhere in a
deep south and somebody fully agrees on
an a joke of a buns where you'd expect
somebody in the south to be all pro-gun
or whatever you know Stevie you really
you never know who's listening never
know who's laughing never know what
they're laughing at I'll give you a
great story so
I was hired to do Joe they work this
woman asked me I got wearing new but
anyway she said would you be interested
in doing a show for a sorority and it's
like hell yeah right yeah
bunch of women at college shirt this is
my younger days uh-huh so I get to the
show I get to the show and it's this
room full of old women and the sorority
was they raise money for charities and
they give money to charity right so the
first comic goes up and he dies a
horrible death I mean just because he's
trying to figure out what do you joke to
a roomful of old women about you know so
the next comics up and he is also just
it's just watching a sinking ship which
is always fun of course because somebody
else Boris the woman leans over to me
she the woman leans over to me she said
and this woman is in her 60s and she's
one of the younger women at this event
and she leans over she says listen these
guys are worried about what to say said
you know how all US women met and she
said we used to send the boys off to war
if you know what I mean they were a
bunch of dirty old women it was [ __ ]
hilarious
so once I knew that then I could go you
know and they loved it and they laughed
and they had a good time so again when
you talk about reading the audience the
thing about being a comic is you got to
learn to listen hmm
everyone thinks it's talking it's
listening you got to learn to listen you
listen to what the crowd laughs at you
listen to what they react to then you
know who you're talking to but trying to
just come out and read and say this is
gonna be this is gonna be down also and
once again what are you gonna do are you
gonna change your whole act because you
think this crowd is blank so now you're
gonna try to rewrite 45 minutes in your
head like no that's not gonna happen so
you got to do what you do you know that
you're not gonna be a different person
you know why
bill burr in Philly okay watch go to
youtube look up Bill burr in Philly and
watch how to handle a crowd that doesn't
like you that clip is famous that clip
is famous you do you as the kids say how
do you start to be able to listen like
what when when did you start to find
yourself being able to listen as opposed
to just like verbal vomit all the time
well it's it's the art of conversation
okay
the art of conversation because in most
conversations people aren't listening
they're waiting for their turn to talk
so you you have to actively learn to
listen to the words people say in in
dealing with hecklers a lot of times all
you have to do is say back to them what
they said and and it's they eat the
crowd laughs cuz they realize how stupid
it was you know so yeah you have to but
it is it is the art of conversation and
app active listening is something you
learn to do you have to focus on it yeah
I found with me it's still something I'm
working on but I found the more
comfortable I am with my material the
easier I can listen to the audience and
how they're responding instead of being
in my own head right right
if you that's what I was saying about
knowing your material backwards and
forwards because you don't want to have
to think about it on stage you know in
and and in time you can do that at
listen I can be thinking I can be
talking and thinking seven minutes ahead
about what I'm gonna do or change or
whatever but it takes time takes
experience I'm so excited about that I
mean I've been doing it 10 years now but
I still look at people at your level and
I'm like I can't wait to and it's a lot
of hard work and a lot to go but it is
like I can't wait to have like that
superpower and just that almost feeling
of invincibility onstage to where it's
like I've done this so much you know
right how long do you know in that it's
stage mm-hmm not only is it well
I think it happened at different levels
it happened two different levels my
first major thing was doing just for
laughs I was four years in I was
confident I could make people laugh and
I was I was lucky I was naive enough not
to be afraid of the situation
had I known more about the situation I
would have made it big in my head I
would have been more naive when I got
the Last Comic Standing
I was absolutely ready to do Last Comic
Standing George Wallace you talking
about advice from pros George Wallace
had told me he said everyone gets a shot
the trick is to be ready when your shot
comes and I was ready when my shot came
with last comic you you just you get on
stage and a guy named Danny Morra taught
me to stand it was a great old pro when
I started used to do these comedy
workshops every time you go on stage
work on something every time you go on
stage you might change the word of a
joke you might change the order I'm a
big fan of changing your order of your
act to keep things fresh you know this
this guy told me that he worked with
Sinbad and Sinbad would tell him like
okay tonight do your whole act from the
left side of the stage okay tonight
you're gonna do your whole life from the
right side of the stage Sinbad would
throw a word at him and say use that
word tonight and don't but don't use it
like hey here's a word he said just use
that word and it's O so every time you
get on stage you're working on something
you just you have one idea you have
something you want to work on but never
waste the stage time Sinbad is the guy I
saw a frozen bell-bottoms and watching
that specials what made me want to do
stand-up so yeah he's a he's a Sinbad is
incredible because he's clean and he's
funny to everybody there's not a lot of
comics that can work like a you know a
hardcore all-black def jam room and then
go to a County Fair in Iowa Sinbad can
do
that that's been my goal I started here
in Atlanta so some shows it's all white
some shows it's all black but I coming
up I was always mindful of if it works
in one room and not the other then I
kill it
and my goal has always been to be a
little more universal like that and I
guess that came from watching Sinbad
growing up so yeah he can he can
definitely do that there's a few comics
who can do it he's definitely one of
them
oh well let's get to the final question
here because this is talking about
comics j-money the final question oh we
got drumroll sound effect actually final
question comes from Jacob who are some
of your favorite comics to watch
currently man there are so many like I
said before I think Chappelle I think
Dave far and away is the best there is
right now and one of the best of all
time David has attained Mount Rushmore
status so I love watching him work Roy
Wood jr. love rock watching Roy Roy is
brilliant and funny Roy is like friendly
and funny it's hard to explain but I but
I like watching Roy man this list goes
on and on Jessica Carson out of New York
she's out of her mind yes she makes you
laugh every time I see her I just laugh
like I said earlier Louis black George
Wallace is still the master it's like
just watching watching one of the old
masters of the art there's a lot of
younger comics I don't remember them all
you know I don't remember all the names
I just see them and they so so I'm not
I'm not disrespecting younger comics
it's just these are my peers that I know
and I watch but there's there's so many
funny people out there who are doing
this I like watching the Leah's energy
the Leah's energy makes me laugh Joey be
it
jelly's Joey Diaz is you know Rogan says
this all the time he says he's the
funniest human being I've ever seen and
and what what that means mean like Joey
doesn't have to have an act when Joey
goes up there he just starts talking and
no filter zero filter zero [ __ ] given
he just talks and and I love watching
him for that
I've always loved Gabe Iglesias I saw
him when he started he's always been the
funniest ten-year-old kid I've ever seen
you know yeah that that makes him so
funny
Kathleen Madigan I loved Kathleen she
can make me laugh
all the time you know this thing about
women not being funny is the most
ridiculous thing that that I've ever
heard there are so many brilliantly
funny women out there so there's a lot
of comics I can watch that make me laugh
I really like you know I really like I
really like comics that do something
different than what I do mm you know so
so yeah so I like watching comics who do
things different whether they be you
know from outer space like Harlan
Williams we don't know what planet he
came from but we're glad he decided to
visit this one yes or it could be one of
the great storytellers or whatever the
comics that do something different than
me I like watching Tom Papa hope man you
talk about now you want to talk about
confidence in class Tom Papa did his
whole Netflix one-hour without taking a
step you just he just stood at the
microphone and delivered the whole show
notice that yeah you're right
yes yeah he was just saying yet yes just
stood there just stood there and
delivered the whole thing now you want
to talk about a wordsmith you want to
talk about a word try that try doing
that one night try to not move
yeah he's definitely we're trying to get
him on the show again
yeah Papa's just amazing and and his
energy is so beautiful because he
doesn't overpower you she talks and you
come to him you know so takes confidence
yeah definitely yeah one of the Great's
we're we're on his radar he hasn't said
he'll do the show he just I guarantee he
won't do it oh man I was going to find
me he's a much bigger name and he can't
be bothered with the things I do hey
well I did hear you say being on podcast
is like doing jury duty but uh we
appreciate you taking the time to do
this it's for fellow comics you know so
we appreciate you giving back to the
culture here I listen I love I love new
comics who respect the art if you
respect the art I'll respect you if you
just want to go up there and yell and
talk of [ __ ] with no nothing in mind and
you just want to make a lot of noise
then go somewhere else
but if you respect the art then we
respect you and love to help well do you
have any helpful advice you want to
close with for comics I'll keep writing
keep writing right now because the
because we're all locked in and limited
just keep writing just keep writing and
and when we get back out you'll get to
test it and see which of it works in
which if it doesn't but yeah if
something strikes you as funny write it
down and that's all you can do right now
that's all you can do right now oh and
you know what else I would the other
advice I would give and this is
something I didn't really do but up but
I think find a crew find a few other
comics talk with each other right with
each other [ __ ] about [ __ ] with each
other etc etc there are some people who
have done great with this like Amy
Schumer so and Amy made it she brought
up people because they were in her crew
Tiffany Haddish has helped a lot
people because they were in her crude so
when you do that you move up together
and then one gets an opportunity and
hopefully they open up that opportunity
to some of their others and stuff like
that you know you can ya working with a
group helps so I would say do that it
takes a while and it sound funny from a
guy who's done a ton of competitions and
basically built a name doing them but
this is not a competitive sport but you
have to do it long enough to figure that
out
well Alonzo Bodden we have we have our
gone into overtime we appreciate for
being willing to do this please just let
people know where they can support you
and follow you and listen to everything
you have going on so funny
zo fu n NY on Instagram everything else
is at Alonzo Bodden Twitter Facebook
YouTube etc etc please check out please
check out and so on my facebook page is
on my Instagram the nowhere comedy club
that special is gonna be on May 7th I'm
doing it with a guy named mal Hall who's
a brilliant guy who features for me a
lot and yes please check that out
tickets for 10 bucks money's gonna go to
me and to mal and a donation made to
young up-and-coming comics who lost all
their opening and feature spots with
this listen we know that you guys have
lost much-needed money and those of us
who have been lucky enough to make a
little money have a little money in a
bank like laughter heals did a thing and
we're all trying to help so so I'm a big
proponent of helping that so well let's
make 7 yeah may 7th will and it's on
your Facebook page you said Facebook
it's on everything everything I'll keep
posting it but yeah I'll be know we're a
comedy club on May 7th Instagram
Facebook everything all right yeah we'll
be sure to support that thank you to
everyone tuning in thank you - Alonzo
Bodden
for being on hot breath live here all
right say hello to Heffron for me I
definitely will we're talking
Wednesday so I definitely will alright
thanks a lot man you too